Дія безвізового режиму з ЄС поширюватиметься
на країни Шенгенської зони.
Це всі країни ЄС - мінус Великобританія та Ірландія, які вимагають власну візу.
Швейцарія, Норвегія, Ісландія та Ліхтенштейн не є членами ЄС,
але підтримують "Шенген".
В’їзд українцям без віз буде дозволений не довше,
ніж на 90 днів протягом півроку.
Подорожувати до "шенгену" без віз зможуть лише
власники біометричних паспортів. Це головна умова.
У цьому паспорті міститься інформація про відбитки пальців власника.
Крім того, прикордонники можуть вимагати
додатково певні документи, аби перевірити мету подорожі:
- запрошення від родичів чи друзів, якщо ви відвідуєте близьких
- бронювання готелю, якщо ви подорожуєте як турист
- запрошення від ділових партнерів або від організаторів конференцій,
якщо мета візиту - бізнес
- запрошення з університету або підтвердження про
участь у семінарах, якщо ви їдете з навчальною метою
Окрім підтвердження мети подорожі, можуть вимагати:
- зворотний квиток, аби пересвідчитися, що ви повернетеся в Україну у відведений термін
- підтвердження фінансової спроможності:
її доводять випискою з банківського рахунку або ж наявністю готівки
у розрахунку близько 40 євро на добу перебування
- медична страховка
Візитів може бути скільки завгодно.
Утім, слід пам’ятати: безвізовий режим не надає
права українцям на роботу в ЄС.
Це також не дає підстав для виїзду на постійне проживання.
У цих двох випадках українцям і далі необхідна буде спеціальна віза.